Một tháng tư giá dầu dây dân chúng mình tại bạn California của Mỹ đã tăng lý mất các kỳ lục.
Bây phẩy bốn chăm năm đúng là Mỹ một đá lông trong bối cảnh sửa Mỹ Isoran và Iran bước sáng tháng thứ 2.
Mất giá này bữa xa cái lúc trước đó là bây phẩy không trong 12 đúng là Mỹ một đá lông thi lập và thằng sau năm 2020.
Tổng thời tăng sở với một phẩy không trong 12 đá mối Mỹ một ý gà lông khi nhận bình chức.
Châu khi đó, giá dây dân chúng mình tóa quốc ở Mỹ tại một năm phẩy bốn chăm năm tư đúng là Mỹ một đá lông.
Giá sang tại California cũng tò mạnh với sang thường đá năm phẩy tán chăm tả Mỹ bẩy đoà Mỹ bối cả lông.
Sau bối bốn phẩy sau chăm bổ Mỹ bà đoà Mỹ bối cả lông cái đỉnh một tháng.
Theo dưới liệu của bị bà nợ lượng California, dầu dây dân là loại nhiên liệu dạo dạo thông tiểu thuộc nhau thứ 2 tại bán,
chiếm khoảng mới bệnh chăm tổng vệnh số ổ chỉ sau sang.
Bán California là nơi ghi nhận giá nhiên liệu cà miếng Mỹ Isor Khekhao, các quy định mua trưởng nghiêm gặp và hạn chế vệ công phát lọng dầu.